nous avons réussi à faire reculer la
propagation du commis 19 mais pas celle
des variants les propos sont signés elle
d'olivier 0 le ministre de la santé
était accompagné du premier ministre
jean castex pour le point hebdomadaire
sur la crise sanitaire alors après nice
et dunkerque 1 ou a été instauré à un
confinement le week-end on s'attendait à
ce que la mesure soit aussi appliqué sur
d'autres départements où la situation
est tout aussi critique mais ça n'a pas
été le cas
néanmoins vingt départements sont
désormais sous surveillance renforcée en
ile-de-france dans les hauts de france
en provence alpes côte d'azur dans la
drôme dans le rhône la moselle en
meurthe et moselle et en eure-et-loir
alors si la situation ne s'améliore pas
d'ici une semaine les mesures seront
renforcés à partir du week end du 6 mars
et on pourra en parler de confinement le
week end c'est en quelque sorte un
sursis que dans le premier ministre j'ai
demandé aux préfets des départements
concernés d'engager des concertations
avec les élus en vue d'inviter sans
attendre tous les habitants à la plus
grande vigilance et d'envisager dans
tout ou partie de ce territoire des
mesures de freinage proches de celles
mises en place à nice et dunkerque
nous ferons un point au terme de ces
concertations la semaine prochaine et
nous déciderons alors si et seulement si
la situation continue à se dégrader
nous prendrons des mesures renforcées
qui entreront en vigueur à compter du
week-end du 6 mars une situation
sanitaire qui se dégradent donc d'après
le gouvernement qui a annoncé hier le
chiffre de 30 mille cas de contamination
quotidien un record depuis le mois de
novembre
un chiffre qu'il faut malgré tout
relativiser pourquoi et bien parce que
lundi seuls 4000 cas de contamination
ont été enregistrées donc sur ses 30000
qu'a annoncé hier on peut surtout parlé
d'un retard une sorte de rattrapage en
comptabilité sur plusieurs jours
quoiqu'il en soit le virus est toujours
présent et la seule méthode efficace
pour lutter contre sa propagation
reste pour le gouvernent
mais la vaccination si vous êtes âgé de
75 ans et plus et que vous vivez chez
vous et bien vous pouvez prendre rendez
vous sur internet sur le site
sante.gouv.fr ou par le numéro vert
national ou en appelant directement le
centre le plus proche de chez vous il y
en a mille deux cents sur toute la
france peut prendre rendez vous pour
vous faire vacciner avec ce qu'on
appelle les vaccins à arn messager nous
espérons avoir terminé la vaccination de
toutes les personnes âgées volontaires
d'ici à la fin du mois de mars
permettant donc ensuite d'ouvrir la
vaccination aux 65 ans et plus si vous
êtes plus jeunes voire beaucoup plus
jeunes mais que vous figurer sur une
liste de personnes qui sont atteintes de
maladie particulièrement grave et qui
fait que vous êtes très fragile aux
risques du virus vous pouvez aussi vous
faire vacciner en centre de vaccination
avec une prescription médicale avec les
vaccins pfizer et moderna et puis sachez
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui les médecins
généralistes vont pouvoir vacciner leurs
patients âgés de 50 à 64 ans présentant
des comorbidités donc susceptibles de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
voilà qui pourrait donc donner un coup
de boost à cette campagne de vaccination
qui prend son temps pour l'heure seuls
deux millions six cent mille français
ont reçu la première dose du vaccin